[MUSIC PLAYING]
ADAM ABRAMOWITZ: Thank you.
Thanks for being here.
I appreciate it.
I know you're busy.
I wrote "Bosstown"
a few years ago,
pretty much as the Big Dig
was finished, completed.
I lived through the Big
Dig in the South End,
before it was the South
End that you probably know.
And Boston's changed a lot.
And the South End was
a very different place.
Dorchester, Roxbury,
all these places
that are now these are
unrecognizable coveted areas,
were once something
very different.
And the Big Dig
really changed it.
So there was
something that I just
felt I had to write because
I lived through those days
in the '80s, late
'80s, the '90s,
working as a bike messenger and
as a mover, blue-collar work.
That seems to have
kind of disappeared.
Boston used to really
tolerate screw ups very well.
And I was one of the prime
screw ups of the day.
But you could survive in
Boston, during those times,
being a screw up.
And I wanted to get
that down on paper,
just to prove that it existed.
And that's the way it was.
So I'm just going to read
from the opening of the book.
The main character of the
book is a bike messenger,
a job that I did.
And the book actually has
a couple of voices in it;
the voice of his father,
who suffers from Alzheimer's
and used to deal poker
games, a roving poker game,
almost like a
Nathan-Detroit-style poker
game that was sanctioned both
by the mob and by city hall.
His father has Alzheimer's
and knows things about Boston.
And as the streets
are being dug up,
secrets come up and
out of his head,
and also out of the streets,
along with the bodies.
So it's told from--
my main character's
name is Zesty Meyers.
There was a real Zesty
Meyers, actually,
which I'll hopefully
tell you about later.
The book is told in his voice.
But then it also
changes voices into what
his father is thinking
or remembering
from the past in Boston.
So I'm actually going to read
just the opening portion out
of the book, the prologue.
And it starts out,
"Everybody in the game
thinks they're a shark.
This is how I see my
father, circa 1990.
He sits in a high-backed chair,
a deck of Bicycle playing cards
nestled in the palm of his left
hand, his right hand hovering
over the deck like a
magician summoning spirits.
He's wearing a
crisp white shirt,
unbuttoned at the collar.
The sleeves folded into
ruler-width rectangles that
sit just above the elbows,
framing his forearms
and the coiled muscles
that shift like snakes
under his tan, brown skin.
He is smiling, my
father, exposing
a yin yang of upper teeth,
separated horizontally
by a scraggly fault line,
where the bonding was attached
but had yet to discolor to
match the upper portion.
His cheeks are
number 3 sandpaper,
flecked with dull nickel
silver, only partially covering
a lightning-bolt scar
under his bottom lip.
Smile lines run from
the corners of his mouth
into estuaries that reach
the edges of his eyes,
pools of battery acid lit with
a galaxy of pinprick lights
surrounding the pupils.
They are liar's eyes.
Most of my earliest
memories are poker games,
my father caressing
a deck of cards,
the sound of chips hitting
felt, darkened windows, or drawn
shades in rooms,
dense with smoke
and men who, during
breaks in the action,
would practice
staring into mirrors,
trying to erase the light
from their own eyes.
On nights when my father
couldn't find someone
to sit with me and
my brother, Zero,
he would haul us to
these games, where
we would pass the time reading
whatever books and papers were
lying about.
Or if the game was somewhere
with a kitchen or bar,
Zero and I would fix the
mean sandwiches and drinks
in exchange for tips.
Most often though, we just
sat behind, always behind,
our father and watch
the games unfold.
Luck give way to
skill, friendly banter,
wind down into pressurized
silence or muttered curses.
It wasn't unusual
for Zero and me
to appear in school
directly from these marathon
games, our pockets bulging with
ones and fives, hair styled
with palm sweat, clothes
wrinkled and pungent
with cigar and cigarette smoke.
It was not unusual
for me to wake
from a deep sleep in the
nurse's office, Zero laid out
beside me, his hand
squeezing imaginary cards,
dreams of royal flushes
and quad aces dancing
behind sealed lids.
The Z brothers,
they would call us,
the narcoleptic
twins, though Zero
was nearly three years older.
Whether this midday
catatonia brought
my father grief from the
school administration
is highly unlikely, since
those he played with were often
the school officials themselves,
or men otherwise hardwired
to the city's machinery;
politicians and their cronies,
ward bosses and their street
corner protegees, cops,
robbers, bag men,
businessmen, and thieves,
who could tell the difference?
These were the men
who made things happen
and problems disappear.
Dangerous men who
brokered in favors,
cautiously-guarded secrets
that secured their positions
and livelihoods, a few
of which, remarkably
at odds with their
public personas, weighed
like liens on their conscience.
Men who, I was to learn
later, had sometimes
found the weight of those
secrets too great to keep
and would look into my father's
black eyes, those liar's eyes,
and find whatever
it was they sought;
forgiveness, understanding.
In certain Central and
South American countries,
places where the governments
rotate in and out of power,
seemingly through
a revolving door
directly connected
to hell, there
existed a cadre of men and
women who hire themselves out
as professional
hostages, stand-ins
for those taken from wealthy
families and held for ransom.
Though their loved ones ad been
removed from immediate danger,
the families rarely failed to
pay the ransom demands in order
to preserve the honor of their
word, their family's good name.
Whether the hostages are
mistreated or tortured, live
or die, they could care less.
In their world,
reputation is everything.
My father operated under
much of the same principle,
only minus the cold, hard cash.
His word was bond because
generally, it was all we had.
My father was the place
secrets went to die,
never to see the light of day.
At least, that's what
everybody thought.
But then, along
came the Big Dig,
Boston's $20-billion
central artery project,
slicing through the city's
divided neighborhoods,
Charlestown, South Boston,
Chinatown, and East Boston,
the South End, tearing
up the pavement,
exposing the bodies everyone
had figured were buried forever.
What my father knew, or
rather, what he remembered--
as Alzheimer's crept in
and rendered his past
a grab bag of
Etch-A-Sketch memories--
seemed to shift as often
as Boston's topography.
The city and its history
were turned inside out,
one heaping shovel load
at a time, buildings
that had stood mute witness
to decades of fitful change
were reduced to rubble
overnight and carted off
by convoys of trucks
that shook the ground
like many earthquakes
as they barreled
towards the harbor docks.
Two-way streets were choked
into one-way passages, cement
barriers eliminating turns.
Exits and ramps were blocked
and turned around and rerouted
into makeshift outlets.
Rotaries were halved, draining
traffic back to the streets
they had just escaped.
Sidewalks vanished.
Bridges led to nowhere.
Streets disappeared completely.
And as the Earth rumbled,
shifted, and coughed up
its secrets, from every
crack, hole, and crevice,
the rats came out to play."
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you, that's
much appreciated.
That's the serious opening.
Zesty Meyers, the main
character, is quite a wise ass.
So you don't get
it in that opening.
But it comes out as he
barrels around through Boston.
SPEAKER 1: You were
actually talking
about it like, just before,
about the role, about all
the music in the book.
And I know that
that's a huge part
of the book that also
wasn't really in the intro
that you just described.
ADAM ABRAMOWITZ: Right.
Absolutely.
Boston used to be a huge music
town, a really great place
to see music.
A lot of bands
came out in Boston
during those 1970s, 1980s.
Clubs seemingly popped up
and burned down regularly,
under mysterious circumstances.
But Boston, really, it was
just a hotbed of rock and roll.
And at some point, also,
the drinking age was 18.
So people used to
be able to go--
SPEAKER 1: Now we're talking.
ADAM ABRAMOWITZ: Yeah,
you used to go younger.
And fake IDs, they didn't
have any lamination
or any of that fancy code
that probably is required
to get into this building.
So you know, I was
out at the age of 14,
15, getting into trouble
and going to see music.
It was really a huge
part of this town.
My main character gets into an
accident early on in the book.
And it sparks music in his head.
He can't turn it
off, essentially.
Oliver Sacks actually wrote
a book called "Musicophilia,"
I believe it was, which is
hard to get out of my mouth.
But sometimes, it's
a rare occurrence,
but people struck
with lightning, people
with massive strokes,
they develop an obsession
with music, either
to play an instrument
or they hear music
in their heads.
So it's actually
a true occurrence.
But it's very rare
and very obsessive.
So I kind of took
the opportunity
to stick in as many Boston
bands as I could remember
who never made it, who
I loved and respected,
but just never made it.
Maybe one song, they
had Boston popularity.
Which was probably
enough for them,
to have just that lifestyle
and attention early on.
But I'm sure they didn't
make a career of it.
And any questions from you,
please, hit me up with it.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah, all the
music references are cool.
And I was like, frequently
googling some of them.
Like you said, they
didn't make it, you know?
So it's cool.
This is sort of their lasting,
for a lot of them at least.
ADAM ABRAMOWITZ: Yeah I
was always very jealous
of anyone who played
an instrument.
I always wrote.
But you know, who pays
attention to writers?
I only wrote to get girls.
It's the truth.
I'm ashamed and proud
at the same time.
But it only had--
it only went so far.
[LAUGHS]
SPEAKER 1: And then poker is
one of the other main themes,
besides music, in the book.
So you have a good poker--
ADAM ABRAMOWITZ: I do
have a poker history.
So poker is a huge part of the
book with Zesty's father, Will
Meyers.
So poker was the third way
I made money in Boston.
There were always poker
games breaking out
at the moving company
that used to work at.
And there were games often,
if you knew the right people.
And the money wasn't so big.
But it was another way to
make some money across town.
Poker is huge.
The cover of the book,
you'll see a spade
on the cover of the book.
Poker is throughout the book.
I love poker because
it's the one place where
you can sit down with
somebody, lie to their face,
and they don't hate you
because it's expected.
It's just, it seems to be
the great equalizer of lies.
Everybody knows what
everybody is doing.
Everybody.
And the beauty is,
everyone really
does think they're
a good poker player.
No matter if they
lose money, it's
just a bad night or
bad luck or bad cards.
It was really a pleasure
to fleece people based
on their over-inflated egos.
Which I suffered for many
years, because you only
get good at poker through
being bad at poker
and willing to take the hits.
So I took my hits.
SPEAKER 1: Now, how long were
you a bike messenger for?
ADAM ABRAMOWITZ: So I was
a bike messenger through--
how many times did I get hit?
Or how many years?
SPEAKER 1: Both.
[LAUGHS]
ADAM ABRAMOWITZ: So I was a
bike messenger for about five
or six years, on and off.
My largest client,
for those of you
who remember the "Boston
Phoenix" newspaper,
which before it was "The
Phoenix" was a real paper.
So I used to be a courier
for the "Boston Phoenix"
newspaper, which was a
great thing, because it
gave me access to a lot of
different venues and shows.
So for about five or six
years, I was a bike messenger
on and off.
My second-biggest
client was a pot dealer.
Which everybody was
always so happy to see me.
It was really great to
be welcomed like that.
It's a tough job.
But I loved the freedom of it.
I loved being out
in the streets,
making my own schedule.
It's a job that seemed
to die off and then
come back, with everybody
wanting everything now.
You know, there's such a
currency in speed these days.
Everyone wants it, you know,
in the order that they want it.
So I think that the
messengers have actually
made a comeback in town.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah, I
wanted to ask about that.
Because that's like, one of
my favorite parts of the book,
was just the detail of like,
that job sounds really--
even compared to whatever you
know, blue-collar work, I mean,
that job sounded insane.
ADAM ABRAMOWITZ: It
was an insane job.
It's a job that paid off,
in the sense that you
get to meet a lot of people.
You get to meet people
also, really, on the way up.
I recall, actually, meeting--
for the most part,
you get the lobby,
the people working the lobbies.
You get the secretaries or
the personal assistants.
And a year later, they're
in the front office.
And two years later,
they've moved up the ladder.
So it was interesting
to actually see
the rise within all the
different corporate structures.
That people can
begin in one place.
And if they stick
with something,
they really can move up.
So it was a great
job, in that sense.
AUDIENCE: So the
question that I've been
thinking about pertains here.
So bike messenger
and card sharp,
and how did you get
to work at Google?
SPEAKER 1: I was
wondering that too.
ADAM ABRAMOWITZ: So I never
got to work at Google.
Actually, I'm a guest at Google,
and very happy to be here.
I wish that was an
invitation to Google.
But I actually teach in the
inner city, in New York,
I teach in Mount
Vernon, New York.
So that was another thing,
just working with young people,
getting to meet a lot of
young people in the South End.
It started, I was one
of the co-founders
of the Little League in the
South End, the RBI League.
We used to play in a park.
We used to refer to
it as Crack Park,
Because that's what we'd be
cleaning up just to get kids
on the field.
And now they play.
I believe it's Jim Rice
Field in the South End.
It's a beautiful park.
It was really great to start
there and work my way up.
I haven't worked my
way up to Google.
So you can only get so far.
SPEAKER 1: So I wanted to
ask about the characters too.
I mean, one of the things
that stands out in the book,
like, there are a
ton of characters.
It's almost like, I
kind of thought of it
like "The Wire," or
something like that.
A different setting,
but it's just like,
there are so many characters.
So in terms of
coming up with these,
the parents in particular are
pretty complicated characters.
So I don't know if you had any
thoughts on how you came up
with those characters, or
any other characters that
come to mind as like, the
people you want to talk about.
ADAM ABRAMOWITZ: I
really wanted to honor
a lot of the people
that were in my past.
And I didn't ask permission.
I used a lot of real
names in the book,
and just assigned
them a character.
So it's not that I
made them anything
near to what they really are.
But I just gave them
the names of characters.
The parents as well, my
main character's Zesty's,
mom was a radical
and a fugitive.
So she was involved in South
American, Central American
politics, in the book, and
was part of a bank robbery
and disappeared into
the underground.
So she was based on Katherine
Power, who had robbed a Brinks
truck, and a guard was killed.
And was serving time for that.
So a lot of political
history in the book.
But just a lot of the
people in the book,
I just wanted to kind of
give a nod and a shout
out to everybody who kind of
supported me and everybody,
basically, who I loved.
I grew up a little
strange in Boston.
I actually grew up in
communes in Boston,
during the late '70s.
Or actually, a few
communes in Boston,
cooperative living,
the Boston Food Co-Op
was in Austin at the time.
So depending on who
you ask, I either
had 14 parents at
one time, because it
was a house full of grown-ups.
But of course, everyone
thinks that everybody else
is taking care of you.
So you have no grownups
looking after you.
So I really did run
wild during my youth.
But I did, I wanted
just to shout people out
and to give people a nod.
I didn't realize how many
characters were in the book
until St. Martin's Press--
the book's published
by St. Martin's--
and they were crazy enough
to give me a two-book deal.
So the second part
of this, "Bosstown,"
will be out next year.
SPEAKER 1: I believe "suckers"
was the word you used, right?
ADAM ABRAMOWITZ: Yeah, suckers.
Those suckers gave
me a two-book deal.
So high hopes.
I think they were
hedging their bets.
So I understood why they did it.
Because you just never know.
But when the editor
gave me back something
like a style sheet
of notes, there
were pages and
pages of characters.
And I didn't
realize I had placed
so many people in the book.
And everyone was ascribed
just a one-line description.
And I really did not
realize that so many people
were in the book.
And people said, this
is a complex book.
And at one point, I mean, I
patted myself on the back.
But I also thought
that maybe I'd
overstepped the
bounds of characters.
So there was a fair
amount of editing.
I learned to not write
long for the second book.
I was proud of myself.
This was once a
500-page book, which
got weeded down to about 300.
I forget, 340 pages, whatever
the maximum attention
span of today's reader is.
I'm told it's
about 80,000 words.
So between 80,000
to 100,000 words
is that sweet spot of the crime
novel, until you can follow it,
or somebody of that nature,
who can write a paperweight
of a book, that's what it is.
SPEAKER 1: So I mean, I don't
know if you want to go into it.
So you talked about that
the mom is based off of--
ADAM ABRAMOWITZ:
Katherine Power.
SPEAKER 1: Katherine Power.
And then the father,
was there any?
I mean, just totally fictional?
ADAM ABRAMOWITZ: Well, I
did a little sleight of hand
with the father, actually.
I mean, I'm ashamed and proud
of it in the same breath,
to say the main
character is, more
or less, the idealized
version of me,
fast-talking and slick, and
carrying around lots of money,
and always having something
to say to the prettiest girls,
working those front desks.
But the sleight of hand with
the fathers, I have two kids.
And you know, they've grown
up completely differently
than I have.
I wanted to not only let
them know how things were.
But I wanted to
have a memory of me,
when the time
comes for me to go.
So the father with the teeth,
the shattered front teeth,
I lost my front teeth
in a basketball game.
Unfortunately, it was
a Nerf basketball game,
and it was on Christmas Eve.
I took an elbow.
Try getting a dentist
on Christmas Eve.
And so the teeth are mine.
The scar, I got punched--
as my main character
often gets punched--
and my teeth knocked
through my lower lip.
So a lot of the
description is actually,
I've taken you know,
the poker playing.
It's also me.
But it's kind of the older.
me.
So they get the younger
version and the older version.
So I don't know if that's overly
egotistical, if any writer has
ever given the full
range of their being
in separate characters.
But that's really
what it's based on.
SPEAKER 1: It's probably
pretty common, I guess.
I don't know.
ADAM ABRAMOWITZ: I don't
know what other writers do.
As a matter of fact,
I have a deadline.
In case you're wondering
about the bags under my eyes,
it's not just the
lighting, which is great.
But it's just, I'm under
deadline for the next book,
and it happens to be
the end of the year.
So I'm down to a few weeks.
And I've lost my
train of thought.
What was your question?
SPEAKER 1: Well, you were
talking about how you came up
with the characters.
And it sounds like
were saying something.
ADAM ABRAMOWITZ: Oh, I got it.
So I think that was the
lead-in basically, to like,
the writing process
and creativity.
People at Google,
I know, don't just
get hired, strictly that they
can do a straightforward job.
I'm sure that
creativity is something
that they look for,
to be able to work
with a lot of different people
a lot of different ways,
under deadlines
and under pressure.
My writing process
has been the same way.
I actually think of
it as small miracles.
Because I'm certainly not the
brightest person in the room,
especially when I visit Google.
But there's a certain amount
of incubation of an idea
that you need chew it, you
think about it for a long time
before you actually sit
down and present it.
So I incubated the first
book for a long time.
Probably, you know,
longer than I should have.
It's very dishonest
to tell a woman you're
trying to pick up in a bar
that you're a writer when
you haven't written anything.
But sometimes you
just need to really--
SPEAKER 1: Incubate.
ADAM ABRAMOWITZ: Yeah, incubate.
Is gestation the right word?
A gestation period, I think.
So there's a certain
amount of it.
So now, that book
took a long time
and then came out
in eight months
after being fired
from a teaching
job, which is another story
I'm not going to tell you.
Totally uncalled-for firing.
And now I'm under
deadline, although I've
had some amount of time to
think about the second book,
to work under
deadline and to have,
almost, to be forced
to be creative,
is a whole 'nother
ball game, I've found.
And really, a lot of
napping is involved.
I don't know if you have
napping pods here, but--
oh well, God bless.
Nap
Napping pods are great.
We need them in the
school that I teach.
And soundproof napping
pods would be perfect.
But I get up every
morning very early,
sit down, really,
without any idea
of what's going to come out
next, and pray for a miracle.
And something comes out.
It's not that it will stay
in the form that it is.
But from one idea
is born another.
And the pages stack up.
I don't know if that's
a reproducible formula
for creativity.
But I think everybody
is different.
And it's working for me.
And both books really
will have been done
in two very different ways.
So who knows?
SPEAKER 1: Yeah.
So I wanted to ask
too, the book--
something that doesn't
really come across
in the intro, as you
mentioned in the intro--
is more descriptive.
The book is like,
very fast paced.
It's kind of like,
cinematic in a way.
It feels like, you know, it
could be a TV show, a movie.
Are you imagining it as that?
ADAM ABRAMOWITZ: Well,
I'm hurt that you
think the opening is slow.
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER 1: Well, slower.
ADAM ABRAMOWITZ: But no.
I mean, it's a bike messenger.
And everything having to do
with being a bike messenger
is speed.
So when I wrote the book, I
didn't consciously come out
to write a cinematic book.
The movie rights and all
the riches that come with it
were the furthest
thing from my mind.
But it really was
all about speed.
So the whole story takes place
over only a couple of days.
And I knew that speed was the
main formula for that book.
So it does happen quickly.
It does kind of unspool.
I think there's also something
cinematic about talking about
Zesty's father, William,
who has Alzheimer's.
I just think that our
memory is so fallible.
That we think of things
and remember things.
I mean, we can't
predict what it is
that's important to
us in our memories.
We think that we will remember
people and places and events.
And it doesn't work out.
We can't pick and
choose our memories.
So I was always fascinated
with memory and story,
just like any family story seems
to change with the retelling.
Anytime you get together with
somebody, with the same people
over and over again, the story
morphs into something else.
So I do think that memory, film,
that sort of thing unspools.
SPEAKER 1: The music too.
ADAM ABRAMOWITZ: The
music, with the soundtrack,
like, a daily soundtrack.
As a matter of fact, I
mean, that's the thing.
Everybody now provides
their own daily soundtrack.
Everyone's always plugging
in to the headphones.
And I almost wonder whether
it's too much, in a sense.
We have our own internal
soundtracks, I think.
More having to do with
thought than music.
I wonder how much of
that we're cutting off
by constantly being plugged in.
Although it's pleasurable.
I certainly run faster when I'm
plugged in, when I go jogging.
And But I tend to
be less creative
if actually listening to music.
My students, they claim
to work better with music
and to read better with
music in their ears.
But their writing certainly
doesn't reflect that.
So I'm not sure I believe that.
AUDIENCE: I had a question
about the writing process
that you were talking
about a little bit before.
And as a two-part book, do you
find that since the first book
seems to be highly
autobiographical, did
the second book turn out to be
more autobiographical or less,
as were going through
your creative process?
ADAM ABRAMOWITZ: That's
an interesting question.
So I would say, the
second book, I mean,
they did give me
a two-book deal.
So I knew there was
a second book coming.
So there were certain things
that I put in the book, almost
that I knew I would
write more extensively
on in book number two, that
would come to bear fruit.
One of the questions
Jacob asked me,
how long was I a bike messenger?
And six or seven years.
But you can only take such
a beating for so long.
Like, not everyone is Tom Brady.
So I knew that had to get out.
Same with the moving business.
I didn't want to be
a broken-down man.
So I knew that I had to evolve
and get out of the business.
And the character
thinks the same way.
He starts out as a bike
messenger in the second book,
but finds another career that
will bring him, basically,
into crime.
You know, the crime
business, which
is kind of like the
PI business of Boston.
So as far as being creative,
setting yourself up, just
knowing when it's
time to step away,
I guess, and realize
when it's time
to move on to the next phase
of your life, it was the same.
So I think creativity
sometimes can
be forced, if you know
that the clock is ticking.
So I knew that the clock
was certainly ticking on me
in real life, which was
the autobiographical part.
I think it was mirrored
by Zesty's move
away from being
a bike messenger.
When I met my wife,
I hate to say it,
I met my wife at a gym at the
YMCA on Huntington Avenue.
Which was a great
big gay hotspot.
I met my wife in like, one
of the biggest gay hotspots
in Boston.
So when I met my wife, she
used to run on the treadmill.
Which I used to
say, my wife is one
of the stupidest women I
ever met, trying to run away
from me on a treadmill.
But I just think that I
lost my point, because I'm
talking about my wife.
Oh, here's the point.
I'm back with you.
So some people are
forced to do things.
So I wasn't married when
I got my wife pregnant.
We weren't married.
I had no plans on marrying her.
And sometimes you
are just forced
into making these
decisions that spur
on the next chapter
of your life.
It ended up being the
maturing factor for me.
And it just it lights
a fire under you.
So I think creativity comes.
Sometimes it's forced.
And sometimes, if you have
the luxury of time and space,
then that works as well.
I hope I answered your question.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah.
ADAM ABRAMOWITZ: I know
you know way more about me
than you probably should
but thanks for the question.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Since this book
seems to be a bit about pacing
and speed, as someone who rode
a bicycle around Boston a lot
in the '70s without a helmet.
ADAM ABRAMOWITZ: Excellent.
Yeah, me too.
Cool.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Well, I didn't know
what a bike lane was.
Things have changed.
I left for 30 years
and I came back.
And the pace has
changed on bicycles.
You know, now there's
hundreds of them.
And they all go
at sort of a pace.
Have you noticed that?
Is that part of
the book, the fact
that the pacing can change?
Not only in your life,
but clearly in bikes.
Also, when was the
first time that you
saw the word stylish and South
End in the same sentence?
ADAM ABRAMOWITZ:
Hmm, that's good.
Well, certainly, the
pace has picked up.
I mean, the pace of everything
has picked up, really,
in all our lives, I think.
So yeah, bike lanes really
confuses everybody, I think.
I was never a gear head.
Like, I could hardly
fix a flat tire.
I just knew that
getting on a bike
was the way to get around
this city, certainly.
But I mean, when I
was in the South End,
I remember the Greyhound
bus used to be on St. James,
if I'm not mistaken.
It used to be the bus depot.
And I remember that the
buses from New York where
my parents are from, Brighton
Beach, Brooklyn, they
would take the Greyhound bus.
And it would come in
off of 93 and then
cut through the South End.
And I remember coming
through the South End.
And there the Orange line was
still up, and it was dark.
And the streets were just--
the Pine Street Inn, it would go
right past the Pine Street Inn.
Homeless people.
Very dark.
The sun never seemed
to shine in that area.
There'd be a car burning
on the side of the road.
I mean, this was Boston.
This was the Bronx in New
York-- in the 1970s too.
So if you want to call it
a slow burn, certainly.
So back then,
yeah, the South End
was not even on anybody's radar.
JJ Foley's is a bar
that I would pass.
And I believe they're still
in existence in the South End.
Everything has
changed with Boston.
It's amazing.
The borders are gone.
And the way that the
neighborhoods were Balkanized,
practically, you
know that they were
just such unique and
dangerous places to be.
You needed to know where
you were at all times.
And even within their own
ethnic kind of groupings.
Like, the Southie
Irish would kick ass
on the Charlestown Irish if
they crossed the borders.
And you could tell if
you've got the Southie dot
or not, that little
tattoo that they
would have between the
thumb and that little area.
The city was dangerous.
It was wonderfully dangerous.
Because it was
exciting back then.
You knew you were in a place
where you can literally
go a half a mile and see
something completely different,
see a whole different
way of life,
and a different kind
of neighborhood vibe.
So you probably
remember that you had
to know where you were going.
You had to know where it
was that you should be.
And it was good to travel
in numbers, sometimes.
AUDIENCE: So I have
another question for you.
ADAM ABRAMOWITZ: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: There's
clearly a fair bit
of nostalgia in this book
for the Boston that was.
And I arrived in Boston in 1990,
and have been bicycling here
for the last, well,
20-some years.
And that's been marvelous
to watch the transformation
and the Big Dig, in particular.
It went from this absolute
chaos to something
that, honest to God, works.
I mean, I can get to the
airport in 15 minutes, which
is fantastic.
So my question is, which Boston
would you rather live in?
ADAM ABRAMOWITZ: That's a
really, really great question.
I think I'm going
to take the question
and say, which Boston
can I afford to live in?
So it is a heavy
dose of nostalgia
with the book, with the
music, with the city itself.
I didn't realize it.
But you know, when
reviews started coming in
from the book, they
all spoke about Boston
as being a character that,
"Abramowitz nailed Boston."
And I wasn't trying
to nail Boston.
I was trying to be true
to how I viewed the city
and how I saw it back then.
That's a really tough question.
I live in New York now.
And every time I
come back to Boston,
I want to stay in Boston.
There are certain places
that feel like home.
But I don't know if
I fit in anymore.
Because I can't give up
the past in some ways.
Every street I go on,
it drives my kids crazy.
I shouldn't be old enough
to say, this used to be,
and I remember when.
But yet, I can't shut myself up.
Because the city has
changed that much.
The city is beautiful.
This area used to
be kind of barren.
You know, I mean, if I were
to dump a body in Boston,
you know, Boston/Cambridge,
this might be--
SPEAKER 1: Hypothetically.
ADAM ABRAMOWITZ:
Yeah, hypothetically.
[LAUGHTER]
This used to be great.
There was nobody here.
There was nobody.
This was just a pass through
to either get to Beacon Hill
and the Charles Street.
There was nothing here.
There was Legal Seafood,
where I bartended, by the way.
It was just kind
of a pass through.
So I'd love to come
back to Boston.
I'd love to.
I'd love "Bosstown"
to be a film.
I mean, that's
certainly the goal.
Unless you're about
to buy 10,000 books. .
That's the only way I can come
back to Boston and afford it.
But yeah, I have a
great nostalgia for it.
I'm going to be a
terrible old man.
Because it's going
to be endless.
That's a great question.
I really appreciate
everybody coming out here.
There's a great feeling
for an author when
people come by and
listen and just take
a little piece with you.
So thank you.
Thank you for coming here.
SPEAKER 1: Thank you.
ADAM ABRAMOWITZ: Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]